[موسيقى]
يخوض السياسي الشاب احمد سالم حملته
الانتخابيه للفوز بمقعد برلماني عبر
اللائحه الوطنيه للشباب
احد عشر مقعدا فقط هي مجموع مقاعد هذه
اللائحه المستحدث والتي يتنافس عليها 25
حزبا مما يعقد مهمه احمد سالم ومنافسي
الا انه جاء ضعيفا جدا لانه لم يتساوى فيه
الشباب مع النساء واللائحه الوطنيه زياده
عدد مقاعد اللائحه الخاصه بالشباب في
الانتخابات مستقبلا حتى تناسب ما يمثله
الشباب من اجمالي الناخبين مطلب ترفعه قوه
سياسيه ونشطاء وشباب رغم ترحيب الطيف
السياسي بتخصيص لائحه الشباب
[موسيقى]
استحدثت اللائحه الوطنيه للشباب بناء على
اتفاق بين الحكومه والاحزاب السياسيه
سبتمبر الماضي بهدف ضمان ولوج الشباب الى
مراكز القرار لكونهم يشكلون سبعين في
المئه من السكان
ستضمن لائحه الوطنيه للشباب انتخاب احد
عشر شابا دون الخامسه والثلاثين وهو اعلى
تمثيل للشباب في البرلمان الموريتاني منذ
بدايه التجربه الديمقراطيه مطلع تسعينات
القرن الماضي ورغم المناخر التي يبديها
بعض النشطاء والمرشحين الشباب فان هذه
اللائحه براي مراقبين ستكون خطوه مهمه على
مسار التمكين السياسي للشباب ابراهيم
مصطفى العربيه نواكشوط لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات